in the previous video I mentioned that
broadcasting is another technique that
you can use to make your Python code run
faster in this video let's delve into
how broadcasting in Python actually
works let's motivate broadcasting with
an example in this matrix I've shown the
number of calories from carbohydrates
proteins and fats in hundred grams of
four different foods so for example
under grams of apples turns out has 56
calories from carbs and much less from
proteins and fats whereas in contrast
100 grams of beef has 104 calories from
protein 135 calories from that now let's
say your goal is to calculate the
percentage of calories from carbs
proteins and fats for each of the four
foods so for example if you look at this
column and add up the numbers in that
column you get that 100 grams of apple
has 26 plus one point two plus one point
eight so that's 59 calories and so as a
percentage the percentage of calories
from carbohydrates in an apple would be
56,000 59s Delta 94.9% so most of the
calories in an apple on come from comps
whereas in contrast mostly calories of
eve come from protein and fat and so on
so the calculation you want is really to
sum up each of the four columns of this
matrix to get the total number of
calories in 100 grams of apple beef eggs
or potatoes and then to divide
throughout the matrix so as to get the
percentage of calories from carbs
proteins and fats for each of the four
foods so the question is can you do this
without an explicit for loop let's take
a look at how you could do that what I'm
going to do is show you how you can set
say this matrix equal to a 3 by 4 matrix
a and then with one buying a Python code
we're going to sum down the columns so
we're going to get four numbers
corresponding to the total number of
calories in these four different types
of food 100 grams of these 4 different
types of food and I'm going to use a
second line of Python code to divide
each of the 4 columns by their
corresponding sum if that verbal
description wasn't very clear hopefully
you'll be clearer in a second when we
look at the Python code so here we are
in the jupiter notebook i've already
written this first piece of code to
pre-populate the matrix a with the
numbers we had just now so let me hit
shift enter and just run that so let the
meter gray and now here are the two
lines of Python code first we compute
Cal equals a dot sum and X is equal zero
means the Sun vertical you say more
about that a little bit and then just
print Cal so so if some vertically
serves we say just now 59 is the total
number of calories in the apple 239 with
the toe number calorie to the beef and
eggs and potato and so on and then going
to compute percentage equals a over Rho
cow dot reshape 1 by 4 actually we want
percentages multiply by 100 year and
then let's print percentage let's run
that and so that command
we've taken the matrix a and divided it
by this 1 by 4 matrix and this gives us
the matrix of percentages so as we
worked out kind of by hand just now you
know in the in the Apple that was the
first column ninety four point nine
percent of the calories off from carbs
let's go back to the slice
so just to repeat the two lines of code
we had this is what we have written out
in the Jupiter notebook so as a bit of
detail this parameter axis equal zero
means that you want Python to some
vertically so this is x is zero
vertically whereas the horizontal axis
is X this one saluton right axis one or
some horizontal uses on birth degree and
then this command here this is an
example of pipes and broadcasting where
you take a matrix a so this is a 3 by 4
matrix and you divide it by a 1 by 4
matrix and technically after this first
line of code Cal the variable count is
already a 1 by 4 matrix so technically
you don't need to call reshape here
again so that's a little bit redundant
but when I'm writing typing codes if I'm
not entirely sure what matrix what are
the dimensions of a matrix I often will
just call a reshape come on just to make
sure that is you know the right column
vector with a row vector or whatever you
want it to be the reshape command is a
constant times order one operation this
is very cheap at all so don't be shy
about using the reshape c'mon to make
sure that your matrices are the size you
needed to be now let's explain in
greater detail how this type of
operation works right we have a 3 by 4
matrix and we divided it by a 1 by 4
matrix so how can you divide a 3 by 4
matrix by ax by a 1 by 4 matrix about 1
by 4 vector let's go through a few more
examples of Broadcasting if you take a 4
by 1 vector and add it to number what
Python will do is take this number and
also expand it into a 4 by 1 vector as
well as follows and so the vector 1 2 3
4 plus the number 100 and ends up with
that vector on the right you're adding
100 to every element so in fact we use
this form of broadcasting where that
constants was on the parameter B in an
earlier video and this type of
Broadcasting were also both column
vectors and row vectors and in fact we
use a similar form of broadcasting
earlier with the constant we're adding
to a vector being the parameter B in
logistic regression
here's another example let's say you
have a 2 by 3 matrix and you add it to
this 1 by n matrix so the general case
would be if you have some m by n matrix
here and you add it to a 1 by n matrix
what python will do is copy the matrix M
times to turn this into an M by n matrix
so instead of this 1 by 3 matrix will
copy it twice in this example to turn it
into this also 2 by 3 matrix and they'll
add these so you end up with this sum on
the right ok so you've taken your added
100 to the first column and the two
inches to the second column added 300 to
the third column and this is basically
what we did on the previous slide except
that we use a division operation instead
of an addition operation just one last
example one of you have a M by n matrix
and your hand is to an M by 1 vector an
M by 1 matrix then just copy this n
times horizontally so you end up with an
M by n matrix so as you can imagine the
copy and horizontally three times and
nando's so we add them you end up with
this so we've added 100 to the first row
and add it 200 to the second row here's
the more general principle of
broadcasting in Eisen if you have an M
by n matrix and you add or subtract or
multiply or divide or they 1 by n matrix
then this will copy it n times into an M
by n matrix and then apply the addition
subtraction multiplication or division
element-wise
conversely you were to take the n by n
matrix and add subtract multiply divide
by an M by 1 matrix then also this will
copy it now n times and turn that into
an M by n matrix and then apply the
operation element-wise just 1 on the
phone forecasting which is if you have
an M by 1 matrix so that's really a
column vector like 1 2 3 and you add
subtract multiply or divide by a real
number so we get 1 by 1 matrix so such
that was 100 then you end up copying
this real number n times until you also
get another n by 1 matrix and then you
perform the operation which is addition
on this example element twice and
something similar also works for row
vectors the fully general version of
Broadcasting can do even a little bit
more than this if you're interested you
can read the documentation of a numpy
and look at broadcasting that
documentation that gives an even funny
more general definition of broadcasting
but the ones on this slide are the main
forms of broadcasting being ended up
needing to use when you implement in
your network before we wrap up just one
last comment which is for those of you
that are used to programming in either
MATLAB or octave if you've ever used the
malleable octave function bsx fun in
neonatal programing bsx fun does
something similar not quite the same but
is often use for a similar purpose as
what we use broadcasting in Python for
but this is really only for very
advanced
malim in octave users if you've not
heard of this don't worry about it you
don't need to know it when you're coding
up neural networks in Python so that was
broadcasting in Tison I hope that when
you do the program homework there
broadcasting will allow you to not only
make your code run faster but also help
you get what you want done with fewer
lines of code
before you dive into the pro-- exercise
I want to share with you just one more
set of ideas which is that there are
some tips and tricks that are found and
reduces the number of bugs in my Python
code and then I hope will help you too
so that let's talk about that in the
next video